wir schauen auf der nächste thema das
hier im plenarsaal diskutiert wird da
geht es um den bundeswehreinsatz in mali
von der un es gibt zwei
bundeswehreinsätze in mali also zwei
einsätze an denen die bundeswehr
beteiligt ist jetzt wird erst einmal der
blauhelm mission besprochen die seit
2013 ja in mali zum schutz der
zivilbevölkerung ist die situation in
mali ist schwierig schon seit jahren
versuchen
konflikte versuchen islamistische
extremisten dort an die macht zu kommen
und
es gab allein seit august 20 20 zweimal
ein militärputsch es gibt ziemliche
konflikte zwischen herrn militär runter
und den westlichen ländern und nicht
zuletzt gab es berichte über ein
massaker an zivilisten in mora bundes
außenministerin annalena baerbock war
gerade in mali sie wird hier auch als
erstes sprechen in dieser debatte
wir schlafen nicht wir haben angst das
waren die worte die uns lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen mich und möchte
mich auf der reise nach mali begleitet
haben als allererstes gesagt haben als
wir zusammen saßen bei 45 grad im
schatten
ingo wo wir unsere dort stationierten
soldatinnen und soldaten im rahmen von -
mal besucht haben wir schlafen nicht die
haben angst weil wir kaum sicher sind
dass wir morgen noch auf den markt gehen
können wir schlafen nicht wir haben
angst weil unsere kinder nicht mehr
wirklich sicher zur schule gehen können
diese frauen diese männer diese väter
diese mütter fürchten sich vor
terroristischen schergen die in den
dörfern in der dortigen region angst und
schrecken verbreiten und wir haben
gemeinsam die menschen dort vor ort
gefragt was braucht ihr als aller
wichtigstes und die antwort kam sofort
sicherheit sicherheit sicherheit und
genau darum geht es bei diesem - mandat
und es geht auch um unsere eigene
sicherheit weil wir nicht wollen dass im
saal rückzugsräume für international
vernetzte terrororganisation
entstehen für organisierte kriminalität
denn gewissen wenn sich - mal aus mali
zurückziehen würde dann würden das
vakuum noch mehr andere kräfte füllen
das gilt für islamistische kämpfer aber
es geht eben auch für russische kräfte
die berichte die wir in den zeitungen
gelesen aber die wir natürlich auch vor
ort gehört haben über
menschenrechtsverletzungen durch
malischen und russische truppen sind
furchtbar und sie zeigen auch auf ganz
deutliche weise worum es für uns ja auch
geht nämlich uns diesen kräften
gemeinsam mit den menschen vor ort
entgegen zu stellen die nicht auf
menschenrechte geben nichts auf
demokratie und nichts auf eine
regelbasierte ordnung und auch deswegen
und davon bin ich zutiefst überzeugt
müssen wir hier engagiert bleiben gerade
jetzt in diesem moment wo russland
seinen grausamen krieg in der ukraine
führt bei wir
weil wir geben nichts sagen und ja das
ist eine politische entscheidung wir
konzentrieren uns nur noch auf das was
vor unserer eigenen haustür passiert was
unglaublich wichtig ist sondern ganz im
gegenteil
genau in diesem moment nehmen wir weiter
unsere verantwortung in der welt war
gerade jetzt und auch das ist die
botschaft die wir mit der unterstützung
dieses - mandates senden deutschland ist
der größte westliche truppensteller in
mali wir bringen dort fähigkeiten ein
die andere beteiligte praktisch nicht
ersetzen können heron drohnen
transporthubschrauber wir sind in gang
an die nation für gegen estland irland
litauen luxemburg die niederlande die
schweiz das heißt die soldatinnen und
soldaten aus diesen ländern sind auch
auf unseren schutz und die unterstützung
der bundeswehr angewiesen
und deswegen entscheiden wir wenn wir
dieses mandat heute nicht zu bestimmen
würden dass wir uns eben auch aus dieser
verantwortung gegenüber den anderen
zurückziehen würden ich glaube dann
droht ein dominoeffekt der die mission
im ganzen schwer treffen würde und zwar
nicht nur für die westlichen
truppensteller sondern das ist ja eine
breite un mission sondern dann auch für
truppensteller aus bangladesch sri lanka
niger oder dem senegal und wir sehen
auch wir sind ein weitergereist
gemeinsam in dem sehr dass es eben
effekte auch für das dortige land nichts
einer
demokratischen regierung hätte
es stimmt das möchte ich auch ganz offen
und deutlich sagen weil von schönrederei
halte ich nichts erst recht nichts in
mandaten die situation in mali ist alles
andere als einfach auch das haben wir
gemeinsam liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die mit waren dort vor ort in bamako
erlebt ich habe deswegen dem präsidenten
dem übergangspräsidenten
goitzsche und dem außenminister die ob
auch dieser geputschten regierung sehr
sehr deutlich gemacht der übergang zu
einer gewählten regierung darf nicht
weiter verschleppt werden das fordern
wir nicht nur von europäischer seite
sondern
gemeinsam mit ricco groß und auch der vn
sicherheitsrat aber ich möchte eben ganz
deutlich sagen diese - mars mission
sichert nicht die malische regierung ab
der einsatz unterstützt die malische
bevölkerung menschen die auf den markt
gehen wollen kinder die endlich wieder
in die schule wollen
und natürlich wissen wir dass es für
stabilität mehr braucht als militär
diese mission alleine wird nicht alleine
für stabilität sorgen aber andersherum
gilt es eben auch ohne ein mindestmaß an
sicherheit ohne diesen mindestmaß an
militärische schutz wird es eine
politische arbeit gerade auch von der
internationalen gemeinschaft dort kaum
weitergeben können dass sie sie eben
dann auch dass unser andere morgen
dialog prozess in den regionalen vor ort
gerade auch im medizinischen bereich im
klimaschutz bereich im
menschenrechtsbereich so nicht
weitergehen könnte daher betrachten wir
die lage so wie sie ist kompliziert
komplex aber wir stellen uns dieser
herausforderung die
verteidigungsministerin und ich haben
deswegen auch gegenüber dem
generalsekretär der vereinten nationen
und unseren bündnispartnern und
bündnispartnern deutlich gemacht dass
jetzt in dem moment wo die französischen
kollegin angekündigt haben ihre
unterstützungsleistung im herbst
wahrscheinlich zurückzufahren dass wir
bis dahin ersatz für die
kampfhubschrauber brauchen wir als
deutsche schlagen indem man davor als
deutsche bundesregierung dass wir
personell aufstocken von 1100 soldaten
auf 1400 und auch technisch vor allen
dingen den flughafenbetrieb weiter
unterstützen denn natürlich gilt die
verantwortung für sicherheit nicht nur
den menschen vor ort sondern auch
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten und
deswegen sagen wir auch sehr deutlich in
diesem mandatstext wenn der schutz für
deutschen soldatinnen und soldaten nicht
mehr ausreichend gewährleistet werden
könnte dann werden wir natürlich unseren
beitrag anpassen und wenn nötig auch
beenden ja diese mandats entscheidung
ist schwieriger als vor einem jahr ich
glaube aber wie es auch wichtiger als
vor einem jahr wir möchten die deutliche
botschaft setzen deutschland zieht sich
in der welt nicht zurück trotz und
gerade wegen des krieges in der ukraine
bleiben wir international im rahmen der
vereinten nationen engagiert wir
überlassen die internationale ordnung
nicht gehen jenigen die keine
menschenrechtlichen und
völkerrechtlichen skrupel haben wir
zeigen flagge für die sicherheit der
menschen in mali und für unsere
gemeinsame internationale sicherheit
herzlichen dank ich bitte um
unterstützung diesmal gab
annalena baerbock die bundes
außenministerin hat hierfür eine
verlängerung des bundeswehreinsatzes
geworben als parlamentsarmee darf die
bundeswehr nur ins ausland geschickt
werden wenn das parlament dem zugestimmt
ich möchte an dieser stelle sagen wir
freuen uns alle dass sie heil aus kiew
zurück sind sie haben einen guten besuch
gemacht es war zeit dass die
bundesregierung sich in hilfe ersticken
lassen und auch wir als opposition waren
stolz auf ihren auftritt in den letzten
tagen in kiel
ich kann ihnen trotzdem nicht ersparen
dass wir natürlich erhebliche probleme
haben mit dem was die bundesregierung
uns heute hier zur fortsetzung des - der
deutschen beteiligung an - in mali
vorlegt also zunächst einmal hat das
bisher noch nicht gegeben dass die
bundesregierung um 13 uhr 35 den
mitgliedern des deutschen bundestages
den mandatstext zuleitet der um 15 16
uhr 30 also knapp drei stunden später
hier beraten werden soll wenn sie
parlamentsbeteiligung wirklich ernst
nehmen dann müssen sie uns auch die
gelegenheit lassen und die gelegenheit
geben und mit den mandatstext
auseinandersetzen bevor wir hier in
einer erste lesung eintreten
und ich weiß dass der eine oder andere
kollege aus der regierungsposition jetzt
haben sich unter dem tisch beifall
geklatscht hat ich finde wir sollten
unbedingt dafür sorgen dass das so etwas
nicht wieder passiert sondern dass wir
was die fristen angeht uns doch
parlamentarischer verhalten
das kritische
was daraus was vielleicht darauf
hindeutet dadurch dass es so verzögert
worden ist ist das natürlich auch das
mandat mit heißer nadel gestrickt dass
wir wissen seit zwölf monaten das am 31
mai die beiden mal die mandate auslaufen
wir wissen seit dem 17 februar dass die
franzosen ihre
komponenten ihre wichtigen wesentlichen
komponenten die auch für unseren einsatz
entscheidend sind abziehen werden und
dennoch haben wir auch bestimmte
anforderungen an dieses mandat auf
moritz bisher auf die franzosen
verlassen konnten keine antworten
gefunden und auch sie haben bisher in
diesem mandatstext und in der begründung
keine antwort gegeben es bleibt die
frage offen
die luft nach unterstützung für deutsche
soldaten und soldatinnen und soldaten im
einsatz und für unsere partner in grau
bereitgestellt werden kann die flugzeuge
unserer partner in der hauptstadt bamako
sind zu weit weg wir haben keine
helikopter mehr vor ort ich frage die
bundesregierung was hat sie unternommen
um sicherzustellen dass diese komponente
ausgefüllt wird haben sie vielleicht
auch unkonventionelle überlegungen
angestellt dass so etwas vielleicht auch
drohnen bewaffnete drohnen aus israel
die man vielleicht lesen könnte oder so
übernehmen könnten denn ich glaube ohne
diese luft nach unterstützung ist der
einsatz deutlich gefährlicher als es
heute ist und das bereitet uns große
bauchschmerzen
ähnliche bauchschmerzen haben wir auch
im blick auf die sogenannte rolle 2 in
der medizinischen versorgung wir haben
letztes jahr einen angriffe auf deutsche
kräfte gehabt mit zahlreichen
verwundeten wir mussten uns auf andere
abstützen das hat dann zusammenarbeit
mit bis hinein in die chinesische
mission gegeben das ist auch etwas was
jetzt wenn die franzosen sich
zurückziehen nicht mehr der form
gewährleistet ist auch da hätte man
genügend zeit gehabt in den letzten
monaten klare regelungen zu treffen dass
diese medizinische versorgung im notfall
auch in dieser rolle 2 bereitgestellt
ist das ist das zweite das dritte ist
der flughafen muss operabel bleiben in
jeder hinsicht denn unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten in daraa sind darauf
angewiesen dass diese luftbrücke für
versorgungsgüter vielleicht auch im
notfall für den abtransport von
verwundeten steht und wenn das nicht
geleistet werden kann dann ist dieser
einsatz in seiner substanz gefährdet und
dann haben wir große bauchschmerzen den
zuzustimmen ich schlage ich sage dass
die bundesregierung das in den letzten
monaten versäumt hat die nötigen
vorbereitungen zu treffen diese lücken
auszufüllen der hinweis allein auf die
un die verantwortlichkeit den lasse ich
nicht gelten denn das sind die vereinten
nationen die vereinten nationen sind ja
nur so stark wie die partner die sie
gemeinsam bild und deutschland will und
will ein starker partner sein und ist
ein starker partner der un also wir
müssen im zweifel auf diesen schuh
anziehen hubschrauber haben wir ja bei
der bundeswehr vielleicht nicht minuten
kampfhubschrauber aber für andere zwecke
also irgendwie eine lösung zusammen zu
bringen wird ja wohl bitteschön möglich
sein denn auch wir glauben dass dieser
einsatz richtig und wichtig ist wir
haben die richtige begründung geliefert
der begründung schließe ich mich an ich
möchte nicht dass molly zum hort von
terrorismus wird ich möchte auch nicht
dass sie sich sicherheit in mali allein
durch von russland bezahlte söldner
unter missachtung von menschenrechten
und kriegsvölkerrecht wahrgenommen wird
das muss die vereinten nationen machen
und wenn die vereinten nationen sich
nicht auf deutschland verlassen kann auf
wen sollen sie sich denn sonst verlassen
in diesem sinne werden wir harte
beratungen über dieses mandat an bevor
wir nächste woche dann die entscheidung
treffen ob es verlängert oder nicht als
oppositionsfraktion herzlichen dank
der sprecher für auswärtiges der
unionsfraktion jährigen hart war das hat
hier noch einmal betonte man müsse sich
auf deutschland doch verlassen
schließlich
und auf ihn wird jetzt antworten
christine lambrecht
bundesverteidigungsminister
genau das sind die fragen mit denen wir
uns beschäftigen müssen dann wenn die
franzosen ab 10 beziehungsweise jetzt
schon vorher aber das sind die fragen
die beantwortet werden müssen und jetzt
kann man sagen das kann deutschland
alleine machen das kann deutschland
nicht alleine machen aber wir werden
unserer verantwortung bewusst
beispielsweise dadurch dass wir sehr
wohl sagen werden eine fähigkeit die
fehlen wird wenn frankreich ab zieht
nämlich die medizinische versorgung da
sehen wir uns in der lage das zu
gewährleisten
diesen rollstuhl standard aufrecht zu
erhalten das ist ganz wichtig dass sich
die soldatinnen und soldaten darauf
verlassen können dass wenn es zu so
einer situation kommt dann die
bestmöglichste medizinische versorgung
gewährleistet ist dass zu sehen wir und
deswegen haben wir auch die obergrenze
in bezug auf die möglichkeiten für
soldatinnen und soldaten angehoben weil
wir das mit gedacht habe und sie haben
genau den finger in die wunde gelegt
russia problematisch werden wird denn
das ist ein mandat wo wirklich große
große erwartungen an uns gestellt werden
an unsere soldatinnen und soldaten die
dort eine hervorragende arbeit machen in
bezug auf die aufklärung mit strähnen
aber auch mit aufklärung vor ort durch
gespräche und dort in der lage dann sind
ein entsprechendes lagebild all
denjenigen zu können zu geben die diesen
wichtigen kampf gegen extremisten gegen
terroristen führen und deswegen ist es
so wichtig dass wir auch alles versuchen
damit genau diese arbeit diese
hervorragende arbeit weitergeführt
werden können da kann ich aber nicht
sagen
das machen wir auch das muss einfach so
weitergehen sondern ich als
verteidigungsministerin sehe mich da
sehr wohl in der verantwortung dafür zu
sorgen dass der bestmöglichste schutz
für unsere soldatinnen und soldaten dann
auch gewährleistet ist und wenn die
fraktionen ab 10 im sommer im herbst
dann wird es diese lücke geben denn
diese diese kampfhubschrauber sind
erforderlich dass diejenigen die
rausfahren die aufklären dass die sich
auch darauf verlassen können dass sie
bestmöglichst bestmöglich geschützt wird
und dieser herausforderung
sie haben sowohl die außenminister als
auch ich mehrfach bei den vereinten
nationen vorgetragen mehrfach deutlich
gemacht dass wir sehr wohl bereit sind
diese aufgabe fortzuführen dass aber
diese lücke geschlossen werden muss und
da ist die vereinzelt sind die vereinten
nationen jetzt auch in der verantwortung
und da bestehen wir auch darauf deswegen
ist es auch so im mandat angelegt erst
wenn diese voraussetzung erfüllt ist
dann können wir auch weiter bleiben und
genauso klar ist es angelegt zu dieser
schutz ist uns wichtig und ohne diesen
schutz können wir dort nicht weiter habe
genauso wie die dritte frage wie geht es
weiter mit dem flughafen in grau mit dem
brandschutz der damit verbunden ist auch
das ist eine aufgabe die zu beantworten
ist und da kann man nicht einfach immer
nur sagen ihr deutsche ihr seid
willkommen ihr deutsche leistet
hervorragende arbeit ja das ist so aber
wir müssen auch dafür sorgen dass
diejenigen die diese hervorragende
arbeit leisten dann auch die
entsprechenden rahmenbedingungen
vorfinden und deswegen ist es in der
verantwortung der vereinten nationen
hier mandat geben dann auch entsprechend
auszustatten dass genau diese
voraussetzungen erfüllt sind und
ich sehe mich da keineswegs aus der
verantwortung zurück ich habe schon
deutlich gemacht wir sind bereit bei der
medizinischen versorgung aufzustocken
und diese verantwortung zu übernehmen
und ich habe auch versucht mit anderen
ländern zu klären und welche
möglichkeiten gibt es denn hättet ihr
solche kapazitäten um diese lücke zu
schließen habe ich aber ganz viel
abwinken erlebt von verschiedenen
staaten ich habe da auch großes
verständnis dafür weil wir alle
natürlich momentan auch militärisch
unter großen herausforderungen arbeiten
müssen weil die anforderungen haben aus
der nato aus anderen militärbündnis und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass die
vereinten nationen das koordiniert und
das abstimmt wenn sie dieses mandat
weiterführen und ich sage ganz klar ich
finde dieses mandat ist wichtig und
unser engagement ist auch wichtig denn
die menschen leiden die menschen im
gesamten sachen leiden unter den
problemen die sie davor finden dass es
gewalt das ist terrorismus extremismus
es gab zwei militärputsche in mali es
ist eines der ärmsten länder der welt
und die versorgung insbesondere mit
lebensmittel die wird jetzt noch mal
verschärft werden auch durch diesen
ukraine krieg und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir präsent sind das ist
auch die klare aussage dieses mandates
wir wollen das weiterführen wir wollen
weiter dafür sorgen dass das bisschen
sicherheit dass durch - mal gewähren das
wird dass es auch in zukunft sein kann
diese ganz klare botschaft senden wir
von hier mit diesem mandat genauso aber
auch die botschaft dann macht die
hausaufgaben dann sorgt dafür dass
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten für
diesen hervorragenden einsatz auch
bestmöglich geschützt sein können und
dann werden wir dieses mandat auch ford
finden genauso ist es angelegt und
genauso ist es auch richtig weil wir den
sahel bei der diese region nicht sich
selbst überlassen dürfen weil wir das
bisschen sicherheit das wird beim genuss
mehr gewährleistet ist weiterführen
müssen deswegen lassen sie uns alle
gemeinsam jeder da wohne möglichkeit
besteht auch gegenüber den vereinten
nationen die zeit die wir noch haben
deutlich machen wir bleiben da wir
leisten unseren beitrag wir helfen zur
stabilisierung beizutragen aber dann
müsst ihr auch dafür sorgen dass die
voraussetzungen erfüllt sind deswegen
bitte ich um unterstützung für dieses
mal
[Applaus]
1400 soldatinnen und soldaten
wir sollen hier bei diesem mandat nach
mali gesandt werden können das ist eine
erhöhung wie
und verteidigt wurde das eben von der
bundesverteidigungsministerium lamprecht
auch referentin die werte kollegen
ministerin
bereits zu den mandatsverlängerungen von
minus 20 20 und 20 21
haben wir das scheitern der
bundeswehreinsätze in mali festgestellt
erst im februar dieses jahres haben wir
im rahmen einer aktuellen stunde die
sofortige beendigung von minus x und eu
tm gefordert die frage die zentrale
frage stellt sich doch wessen interessen
dient unsere militärische präsenz im
saal letztendlich noch
und es ist mehr als legitim zu fragen ob
die lage in mali überhaupt noch eine
friedenssicherung mission zulässt und
inwiefern die anwesenheit
internationaler truppen die situation
für die menschen doch eher
verschlechtert hat
die bundesregierung sollte die
erkenntnis samuel huntington zu
akzeptieren dass ein militärisches
engagement in einem kulturell fremden
land langfristig wohl zum scheitern
verurteilt ist
die ehemalige kolonialmacht frankreich
intervenierte auf bitten der malischen
regierung und mit belehrungen des un
sicherheitsrates im jahr 2013 und
stoppte mit der operation zerfall den
angriff der dschihadisten auf den süden
malis die französische geführte
nachfolger operation war keine hat dann
ab 2014 den kampf gegen den terrorismus
im gesamten saal geführt - mal als un
friedensmission in mali soll dagegen
stabilisierend auf staat und armee
wirken und die bevölkerung vor
übergriffen schützen
terrorbekämpfung ist nicht mandats
inhalt von - man
die deutsche beteiligung an - mal
beschränkte sich anfangs auf
lufttransport und luftbetankung mit
maximal 150 soldaten und war in erster
linie wohl der deutsch französischen
freundschaft geschuldet
ab 2016 wurden auch bodengebundene
kräfte eingesetzt und der mandats rahmen
auf 650 soldaten erhöht der bekannte
effekt des mission creep also der
schleichenden auftrags ausweitung führte
nun jahr für jahr zur erweiterung der
eingesetzten fähigkeiten und zur
erhöhung des deutschen beitrags derzeit
wie gehört bereits
1100 soldaten
diese friedensmission - machen eine
sogenannte robuste mission unter kapitel
7 der un charta ist inzwischen eine der
verlustreichsten
un-missionen seit dem koreakrieg mehr
als 260 soldaten der internationalen
truppe sind bisher gefallen ein
mehrfaches zum teil schwer verletzt
die zahl der seit beginn der operation
in mali getöteten zivilisten soll
bereits die 8000er marke überschritten
haben allein im jahr 2020 mehr als 1000
die stiftung wissenschaft und politik
beschreibt den einsatz der bundeswehr
deshalb als wirkungslos
und weil sich die deutschen soldaten
militärisch zurückhielten ich denke
dagegen es war und ist richtig und
uneingeschränkt zu begrüßen wenn die
deutschen kommandeure die risiken für
ihre soldaten minimieren
[Applaus]
frankreich und insbesondere der malische
armee wird dagegen oft ein hartes zu
hartes vorgehen und auch
menschenrechtsverletzungen vorgeworfen
es wird berichtet dass malische
sicherheitskräfte für mehr vergehen an
der zivilbevölkerung verantwortlich sein
sollen als die aufständischen die er ist
das verhältnis mal ist zur ehemaligen
kolonialmacht frankreich hat sich in den
letzten monaten drastisch verschlechtert
und schließlich zur beendigung der
zusammenarbeit geführt frankreich und
seine partner haben daraufhin die
operation war keine abgebrochen und
werden circa 5000 soldaten aus mali
abziehen der prozess läuft
die zweifel an der sinnhaftigkeit der
bundeswehreinsätze in mali sind also man
kann sie bis zum schluss auch die
wehrbeauftragte des bundestages hat
öffentlich die kritische überprüfung der
einsätze in mali angemerkt hintergrund
sind die jüngsten putsche herunter
kommen sie heute zum schluss ihr redet
seiner verein mit wagner und anderen
russischen kräfte die erfahrungen aus
afghanistan sollten also noch frisch
seien daher währte kollegen werte
ministerin wurden wir unsere und
raclette sie aus mali zurück wenn wir
das deutsche - beteiligung ich danke für
joachim wundrak war das für die afg
fraktionen sitzt auch im auswärtigen
ausschuss für seine fraktion hier erst
einmal in der debatte zum - ein satz der
blauhelm mission in marl die nächster
redner ist marcus faber für die fdp
fraktion
der verteidigungspolitische sprecher
warum sind wir einmal kommen wer
demnächst sogar bis zu 1400 soldatinnen
und soldaten in die un mission minustah
und wie gewährleisten wir deren
sicherheit in mali und in der gesamten
runde sind islamistische terrorgruppen
wie die s miliz aktiv die die stabilität
der region gefährden ohne die un mission
minustah würde das die lage noch
deutlich verschlechtern
und sie würde auch auf andere länder
übergreifen sie wieder fluchtursachen
schaffen das betrifft uns am ende auch
in europa und das betrifft uns am ende
auch in deutschland bekannter kuba die
beiden anti-terror-mission der franzosen
werden beendet
dadurch steigt die unsicherheit massiv
es wird ein vakuum hinterlassen dass es
zu füllen geht um dieses vakuum müssen
auch ein stück weit wieder für meine
damen und herren denn wenn wir es nicht
füllen dann während es andere füllten
dann werden es herumsitzen füllen dann
werden die schlepperbanden film und dann
wird es auch organisierte kriminalität
füllen und das sollten wir vermeiden
und wie
und die französischen streitkräfte
unterhalten hier essenzielle fähigkeiten
auch für unseren einsatz auch für die
sicherheit der bundeswehr
luftunterstützung zum beispiel muss auch
nach dem abzug der französischen
kampfhubschrauber weiter gewährleistet
werden um unsere patrouillen hier zu
schützen leider können wir unsere
kampfhubschrauber tiger nicht entsenden
da wir unter dem cdu csu geführten
verteidigungsministerium eine
katastrophale einsatzbereitschaft
übernommen haben nicht nur in diesem
bereich und die müssen wir jetzt
verbessern deswegen sind wir hier
auftrittes partner angewiesen deswegen
sind wir hier auf bündnispartner
angewiesen und ich bin dieser
bundesregierung sehr dankbar dass sie
sich darum bemüht dass die vereinten
nationen jemand anderen finden der
luftunterstützung
bereitstellt und ist auch wichtig dass
der mandatstext so geschrieben ist das
wenn das ende des sommers anfang des
jahres nicht gelingt dass wir dann auch
mit dem teilabzug beginnen denn wir
können dort nur sein wenn wir auch
sinnvoll etwas beitragen können das wäre
eine katastrophe wenn wir hier gehen
aber wir müssen eben sehen dass wir
nicht gehen müssen weil dann andere
folgen würden
meine damen und herren während unseres
einsatz in die soldatinnen und soldaten
große entbehrungen in kauf wir haben es
eben schon gehört weil bis zu 45 grad im
schatten in einem land das von
wassermangel geprägtes ist es für uns
nicht vermeidbar dass wir den soldaten
und soldaten im einsatz zumuten müssen
dass sie mit zwei minuten duschen am tag
klarkommen müssen was wir aber vermeiden
können ist dass wir sie mit zu wenig
kampflosen für eine mehrtägige
patrouille losschicken was wir vermeiden
können ist das nicht für jeden soldaten
noch ein rucksack dabei ist sondern für
manche nur ein krampf tragetaschen das
war das was ich zuletzt gehört habe als
ich in grau und in mali war und deswegen
ist es absolut richtig dass diese
bundesregierung in die persönliche
ausrüstung investiert dass wir im
letzten monat 2,4 milliarden euro
genommen haben damit unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten nicht nur in mali
bestmöglich ausgestattet sind sondern
auch hier bei uns zu hause das ist bei
jedem mandat wichtig aber bei gerade bei
einem so gefährlichen und zu widrigen
wie diesem hier deswegen stehen wir
freie demokraten zu diesem mandat gerade
mit dieser konditionierung deswegen
unterstützen wir das mandat weiß
zivilisten vor terror schützen wir
unterstützen ist weil das organisierte
kriminalität bekämpft und wir
unterstützen ist weil dieses mandat
schlepperbanden die arbeitsgrundlage
entzieht deutschland leistet hier viel
deutschland leistet luftaufklärung
deutschland leistet patrouillen die für
zivilbevölkerung auch in die fläche
bringen und deutschland leistet
demnächst auch noch mehr nämlich sanität
sanität auch für andere nationen die an
diesem gefährlichen un mission
teilnehmen deswegen sagen wir als freie
demokraten wir unterstützen diese
mission nicht uneingeschränkt aber in
dieser kondition ali sierung ist sie
absolut richtig wir geben anderen
ländern eine chance hier in die
fehlstelle die frankreich produziert
einzutreten und deswegen sagen wir ja zu
- mann und ich danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
ich hatte heute das wort 7 datteln
fraktion die linke
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die bundesregierung will den bundeswehr
einsatz im rahmen der un mission
minustah in mali nicht nur verlängern
jetzt nachdem die franzosen abziehen
wollen wollen sie den einsatz sogar noch
ausweiten durch die anhebung der
mandatsobergrenze auf 1400 soldaten also
mehr noch als zuletzt in afghanistan sie
sprechen dabei von einem
sicherheitspolitischen engagement und
deutschlands das ist die formel die wir
aus 20 jahren krieg in afghanistan
kennen wie in afghanistan soll es alles
seien in mali nur kein krieg in dem
schon mehr als 4000 zivilisten gestorben
sind sie sagen die bundeswehr sei zur
umsetzung des friedensabkommens dort in
mali doch den frieden gibt es nicht die
sicherheitslage hat sich stets
verschlechtert mit der zeit dass alle
gesprächspartner und auf der reise
gesagt das land ist zunehmend
militarisiert die bewaffneten konflikte
haben sich vom norden nach zentral mali
und auch in die regionen ausgedehnt sie
wollen den terrorismus in mali bekämpfen
aus afghanistan wissen wir terror
bekämpft man nicht mit krieg meine damen
und herren und man bekräftigen auch
nicht mit krieg indem man die förderer
von islamistischen terror banden wie
katar und saudi arabien als partner
betrachtet und sie aufrüstet wie die
staatsministerin katja keul das noch
früher gesagt hat die ganz große
kriegskoalition in diesem haus von union
bis grüne kann es noch so oft leugnen
tatsache ist deutschland ist beteiligt
an einem krieg in mali und erkennen sie
es auch endlich an dieser krieg der
bundeswehr in mali ist verloren vieles
daran erinnert an afghanistan und sie
machen mali auch zu einem zweiten
afghanistan und der einzige und warum
sie dort krieg führen ist ja noch nicht
einmal weil sie selbst daran glauben
einen sieg über den islamistischen
terror dort erinnern zu können nein die
bundeswehr selbst sagt ich zitiere aus
den unterlagen die wir bekommen haben
dieser einsatz kann eine
verschlechterung der sicherheitslage
nicht verhindern zitat ende die
bundeswehr kommandeure haben es vor ort
bestätigt sie sagen es geht ihnen nicht
darum
es geht ihnen schlicht darum dass sie
einen geopolitischen fußabdruck man sagt
footprint dazu nennen sie es in mali und
in der region deshalb sind sie dort sie
führen dort mit krieg damit die mali
tische malische putschregierung nicht
noch mehr große militärberater ins land
holt und das ist meines erachtens ein
purer wahnsinn und zeigt es geht hier um
geopolitik und nicht um die bevölkerung
in marley & ich warne auch davor
ich warne auch davor dass sich hier das
bild verstetigt die bundeswehr würde die
wirtschaftsinteressen der ehemaligen
kolonialmacht frankreich hier im sahel
unterstützen weil im mandatstext betont
wird die unterstützung französischer
streit und sicherheitskräfte
die zu recht in mali verhasst sind diese
entwicklung kann nur in einer
katastrophe enden deshalb sagen wir wir
kommen nur aus diesem schlamassel raus
wenn wir die bundeswehr dort
abziehen die bundeswehr-soldaten haben
selbst gesagt muss ich kommen wir zum
schluss der satz der bundeswehr soldaten
war ist dieser einsatz leib und leben
der soldaten wert wir linken sagen nein
ist es nicht deshalb sollte die
bundeswehr abgezogen werden
dagdelen die sprecherin für
abrüstungspolitik und internationale
politik der linksfraktion hat hier
gesprochen und der nächste redner aus
der spd-fraktion karamba diaby
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren so frau kollegin ich
wunder mich sehr über ihre behauptung
bundeswehr führt krieg in mali sie waren
doch mit mir im gau
sie haben doch diese einsatz dort
gesehen die wunde mit sehr sehr dass ich
die behauptung hier machen es geht
vielmehr was anderes ersten april habe
ich ja mit unserer
bundesaußenministerium abhebe reise nach
mali und niger begleitet
mir ist besonders das gespräch in mali
mit maryam naggar lehrerin ausbau in
erinnerung geblieben da waren sie auch
dabei sie berichtete mir uns das land
leidet unter terrorismus instabilität
und den folgen der klimakrise mali ist
wirtschaftlich schwer von den corona
pandemie gebeutelt und hat auch mit den
folgen der ukraine krise zu kämpfen das
angebot für grundnahrungsmittel
verknappt sich
tätig und die preise steigen stetig
mariam us forderungen waren eindringlich
wir dürfen unser engagement in mali
nicht beenden wir du von den schutz der
zivilbevölkerung nicht vernachlässigen
deutschland ist in mali willkommen
wenn wir also heute über unser
engagement in mali diskutieren dann
müssen wir die menschen vor ort im blick
haben und diese benötigen unsere
unterstützung genau deshalb beteiligen
wir uns an - in mali zeit 2013
multilateral und die mission hat den
entscheidenden auftrag das
friedensabkommen von algier umzusetzen
und die zivilbevölkerung vor ort zu
schützen
zu den aufgaben gehören die
stabilisierung wichtige
bevölkerungszentren
der schutz der zivilbevölkerung
die unterstützung humanitärer hilfe und
die forderung der verständigung zwischen
den politischen gruppierungen aber auch
die vermittlung zwischen eco bos und der
regierung - war ist aktuell das einzige
instrument zur stabilisierung in marl
unser engagement trägt aber nicht nur zu
stabilität marlies bei sondern stärkt
die gesamte region und diese stabilität
ist dringend notwendig meine damen und
herren wir haben und nun in mali in
tschad in guinea und burkina faso
erleben gibt diskussion in mali
wäre das eine katastrophe für die
gesamte region
fest steht aber auch der abzug von
frankreich erschwert gefährt die
weiterführung des bundeswehreinsatzes
deshalb ist unsere beteiligung in
aktueller von nur möglich wenn erstens
gewährleistet werden kann dass unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten ausreichend
geschützt sind
zweitens die bestehende infrastruktur
vorhanden bleibt und drittens die un
sicherstellt dass anderer stelle
fähigkeiten luft nach unterstützung zur
verfügung
meine sehr verdrängt haben der schutz
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten ist
jetzt wichtiger als jemals zuvor denn
wir beobachten schon länger dafür muss
ich einmal die aktiv sind
darum begrüße ich die
personalaufstockung auf
es ist richtig dass wir unter den
erschwerten bedingungen denn
bundeswehreinsatz ma lin neu bewerten
und hinterfragt und es ist auch richtig
dass das mandat auch vorzeitig beendet
wird wenn eben nicht bei ausreichender
schutz unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
gewährleistet werden kann klar ist aber
auch ohne den bundeswehr-einsatz können
wir unter den bedingungen unserer
entwicklungszusammenarbeit in also
schwer fortsetzen nur mit hilfe von - ma
können endlos und internationale
organisationen engagiert der
zusammenarbeit bezahlt
meine damen und herren deutschland ist
in mali willkommen jedes engagement
müssen wir nutzen und gemeinsam mit
unseren europäischen partnern und der
regionale organisationen abgestimmt
zusammenzuarbeiten
eine kurzfristige beendigung unseres
engagement in mali wäre eine fatale ist
ideal und würde besonders im gau eine
großes vakuum hinterlassen wenn wir über
den einsatz der bundeswehr in mali
entscheiden muss der schutz der
bevölkerung unserer richtlinie sein wir
dürfen menschen in mali nicht im stich
lassen dankeschön
karamba diaby war das hat dafür geworden
dass die menschen in magie nicht in
stich gelassen werden und damit kommen
wir in dieser debatte zum letzten redner
das ist henning otte mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss der union
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren deutschland hat ein
vitales interesse an der stabilität in
der sahelzone und an der sicherheit im
land mali denn die sicherheit
deutschlands endet eben nicht am
mittelmeer und es muss verhindert werden
dass von mali aus der es terror ein
brückenkopf bilden kann um europa zu
gefährden und es muss verhindert werden
dass die al kaida ableger jane das land
mali nach innen gefährden und hier zu
einer die stabilität verführen wir
danken den soldatinnen und soldaten der
bundeswehr die diesen gefährlichen
einsatz unter schwierigen klimatischen
bedingungen erfolgreich leisten ihnen
gehört unser dank meine damen und herren
und eben weil dieses mandat auch wichtig
aber vor allem auch gefährlich ist
irritiert es ja dass dieses mandat zu
spät jetzt vom kabinett
eingereicht bewirbt dieser eindruck zu
spät und zu zögerlich macht sich ja
insgesamt in der ampel regierung breit
diese zögerlichkeit zeigt sich bei der
antwort auf den krieg in der ukraine
antwort auf die krise in mali und
offensichtlich ist der konflikt
innerhalb dieser ampel koalition das
bestimmende element und das darf es
nicht sein meine damen und herren man
wundert sich aber auch über die linke
und über die afg mit beiden rednern die
ganz nach dem motto augen zum kopf in
den sand agieren wollen aber was einfach
sachlich falsch ist dass sie einen bezug
herstellen zu afghanistan entweder sind
sie nicht gut informiert oder
wissentlich informieren sie die
öffentlichkeit falsch zwei dinge sind
nämlich komplett anders in mali geht man
von insolventen ungefähr unter 5000 aus
in afghanistan waren es weit über
100.000 in der molly haben wir ein
konstruktives umfeld mit der
afrikanischen union mit eco was
beispielsweise ein ganz ganz andere
situationen und sie sollten den menschen
hier keine unwahrheiten von diesem platz
aus
suggerieren
wir werden als union ganz genau diesen
texte beraten ich stelle fest dass
beispielsweise auch die n90 heide
flieger aus meinem wahlkreis nicht zu
der zeit zurückkommen zu der ihnen diese
rückkehr zugesichert war sondern zu spät
kommt jetzt hier die ablösung aber was
uns ganz besonders wichtig ist das ist
der schutz unserer soldaten und da
müssen wir feststellen dass durch den
geplanten abzug der franzosen dieser
schutz der luft nach unterstützung fehlt
und die bundesministerin der
verteidigung hat keine nachfolger bisher
gefunden und außerdem ist für uns die
versorgung wichtig das heißt auch dass
der flughafen militärisch geführt wird
hier hat die
bundesministerin offensichtlich nicht
erfolgreich interveniert bei den
vereinten nationen und bundeskanzler
scholl zeit die die gelegenheit gehabt
mit präsident roh am montag bei seinem
besuch darauf hinzuweisen dass es auch
eine gemeinsame europäische aufgabe ist
hier die interessen so deutlich zum
ausdruck zu bringen und dass beide
ministerinnen gesprächen und offen die
defizite ansprechen macht es ja nicht
besser sie müssen lösungen bieten für
dieses mandat um meine damen und herren
für uns ist es wichtig dass wir eben
dieses schutz und versorgungsniveau auch
gewährleisten können klar eine absolute
sicherheit kann es nicht geben aber zu
sagen wir erhöhen die mandatsobergrenze
von 1000 auf 1400 ja da machen sie sich
aber ein bisschen einfach die bundeswehr
soll es mal wieder richten nein sie
haben die politische führung und die
aufgabe den schutz zu gewährleisten
meine damen und herren
und es ist auch versäumt worden ja
malischen regierung mal deutlich ins
buch zu schreiben dass sie die
kooperation mit den russischen söldnern
sein lassen soll dass das nicht der
richtige weg ist um mal in eine stabile
situation zu bringen besser wäre es die
malischen soldaten so auszubilden dass
sie selbst in der lage sind die
sicherheit zu gewährleisten aber auch da
plant die bundesregierung offensichtlich
die reduzierung des engagements im utm
herr mandat das ja nachher noch beratend
wird das ist besser geht zeigt auch
niger da wird gut ausgebildet durch die
bundeswehr nämlich die nigrischen
spezialkräfte sehr erfolgreich im rahmen
der gazelle aber da planen sie dieses
mandat seien zum jahresende zu beenden
ich kann nur sagen
deutschland trägt verantwortung
deutschland macht diese verantwortung
auch geltend - mandaten
1400 soldatinnen und soldaten von einem
umfassenden 13.000 köpfigen
130000 köpfigen mandat das macht
deutlich wie wichtig der beitrag
deutschlands ist als anlehnung nationen
wir sagen aber auch diese verantwortung
muss verantwortbar sein nämlich das
mandat wir stimmen der beratung zu aber
wir sagen auch sehr deutlich wir machen
unsere zustimmung zum mandat von den
beratungen abhängig und da sind sie
gefordert als ampel und als regierung
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
henning otte war das hat hier als
letzter in dieser
debatte gesprochen zum bundeswehr
einsatz in mali - mal denn es ist
natürlich unter anderem ein problem dass
frankreich nun abziehen wird bis zum
sommer hat so hat es frankreich im
februar angekündigt sollen die
französischen anti terror truppen
abziehen unter anderem nannte frankreich
behinderung durch somalische
übergangsregierung als grund und was
jetzt passieren wird weil die in mali
stationierten französischen
kampfhubschrauber ja ersetzt werden
müssen das ist noch unklar mali wird
auch noch in einer guten halben stunde
hier eine rolle spielen dann geht es um
die ausbildungsmission der eu die
weiterlaufen soll auch allerdings nicht
mehr in mali sondern im nachbarland
niger dort soll dann der schwerpunkt
stattfinden eben weil man
befürchtet dass es sonst zu
menschenrechtsverletzungen durch
malische soldaten kommt die von der
bundeswehr ausgebildet wurden